We now know that the search tree, if we design it this way,
doesn't have to branch into eight possible assignments
but only five possible assignments--those here.
So now my question is, if we design a search tree using this branching here,
how large is that going to become?
I'm going to give you two hints; the first one is
the height of the search tree--that will be n thirds.
Again, we have to take a little bit of care about the details
if we can find such a structure here, but I think I've shown you often enough
in this unit that this is possible, so hopefully you'll just believe me this time
that it's also possible to always find the structure or, at least,
if you don't find one, decide for certain vertices
if they are going to be in the vertex cover or not.
Now how much wider does this search tree get?
It gets very wide, actually; each time you go down into a new level,
you branch into five additional cases times five, times five, times five, and so on.
Now what I would like to know from you--how big is that search tree?
And I would like you to enter your answer here.
It will be some number to the power of n, and I would like you to provide
two digits after the decimal and round up.